[Music]
III is where the biggest games and
consoles get revealed every year but
it's been an industry on the event since
it started in 1995 however fans will be
able to attend the video gaming event
for the first time ever in June I'm Matt
and this is your publicly available
gamespot news update the entertainment
software association has announced that
fifteen thousand tickets will be
available to the public on februari 13
the passes will go for two hundred fifty
dollars or 150 as part of an early bird
discount available on day one they
provide access to the show for panel
discussions and other events from jun 13
to the 15th in addition to special
benefit associated with media veteran
Jeff Keeley's own III programming III
runs from june thirteenth to the
fifteenth and if you can't make it to LA
to enjoy it for yourself you don't need
to worry we'll be covering the show
throughout the week with a bunch of news
previews and interviews on the hottest
games announced so for that and much
more from the world of video games stay
tuned to gamespot